frire le bonjour alors la marche est
terminée exactement elle vient de se
terminer cette marche qui avait commencé
aux alentours de 15h à beaumont-sur-oise
avant un long discours une longue
conférence de presse dassa traoré ainsi
que des proches du jeune homme décédé il
ya quatre ans le cortège s'est ensuite
dirigé à travers la ville de beaumont
sur oise en s'arrêtant à des points
stratégiques c'est alors que la porte
parole du collectif adama traoré sa
soeur à sa s'est exprimé à plusieurs
reprises elle s'est également exprimé au
micro de rtl france vous allez voir pour
l quatre ans après la mort de son frère
le combat pour mettre toute la lumière
sur les causes de son décès continue
m'écouter malheureusement à la mort de
georges klein la mort de notre frère
aussi va avoir un écho fort et puissant
soit la mort de mon petit frère adama
traoré
quand on voit la mort de gerry boyle
dont peut imager la mort de mon petit
frère il a ou non porté le poids de ces
trois policiers de gendarmes sur leur
corps ils ont eu les mêmes derniers mois
je n'arrive plus à respirer je n'arrive
plus à respirer
donc oui les coûts va être fort et
aujourd'hui on la france dénonce vas tu
à ce moment là la france va dénoncer ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis mais il se
passe exactement la même chose en france
et le combat il est aussi ici en france
à travers le nom d'adama traoré comme
d'autres victimes on dénonce le dmf
justice et la révocation qu'elle soit
récusé est laurence laser et on demande
surtout que la requalification des faits
de l'amendement petit frère se soit mis
en homicide volontaire
aujourd'hui c'est un rassemblement qui
est organisée par le comité à damas seul
on a réaffirmé encore une fois notre
indépendance par contre ça lui le climat
génération climat de dénoncer les
violences policières et d'être là
aujourd'hui dans les rues de beaumont
aujourd'hui la vérité elle est là elle
joue juste à la justice joue avec le
temps c'est pour ça que récuse et on me
demande la récusation de la juge qui
instruit dans notre affaire des plus de
quatre ans qui emmène le dossier vers
des non-lieux quatre fois aujourd'hui la
vérité elle est là
demandons nous avons tous les éléments
pour aller vers un procès pour au micro
de rtl france également madjid
messaoudene initiateurs de la marche
contre l'islamophobie qui lui est revenu
sur les violences policières et les
policiers qui selon lui bénéficie d'une
impunité une impunité devenu bien trop
banal écoutez le au micro de la défense
là c'est symbolique mais on est au
niveau de la gendarmerie où est décédé
adama traoré dans l'indifférence
générale
et il est quand même assez évident que
ce sont les gendarmes qui ont laissé
mourir à damas et qui l'ont qui l'ont
qui l'ont tué donc pendant quatre ans
une famille mobiliser des soutiens des
personnalités des collectifs d'autres
victimes qui sont venus dire que ça
suffit que y'en a marre que les noirs et
les arabes dans les quartiers populaires
meur soit sous les balles de la police
soit suite à une arrestation en
utilisant des techniques qu'on sait
dangereuse type plaquage ventrale donc
du monde
beaucoup de jeunes non ce qui est quand
même assez rassurant au vu de ce qui
nous attend dans les prochaines années
donc c'est à eux de prendre la relève
et puis l'appel qui a été cosigné par
génération climat qui qui qui dit bien
qu'il ya des convergences à faire en
termes de lutte et que dans ces
mouvements là il est important de ne pas
saucissonner les causes mais faire en
sorte qu'on se retrouve tous sur un truc
qui est basique à savoir que la peine de
mort est abolie en france et qu'il est
hors de question qu'on laisse des jeunes
se faire tuer par la prise d'autres pays
est désormais maintenant que la marche
est terminée les manifestants se sont
retrouvés sur un terrain de sport
spécialement aménagé pour l'occasion et
c'est là qu'ils peuvent visiter
différents stands et se resterait voilà
cette marche qui vient de prendre fin
ici à beaumont sur oise merci à cannes
il pour toutes ces précisions